welcome everyone
thank you for joining us for our
presentation titled the varied
application
of dried blood spot dbs sample
collection
during the coven 19 pandemic it's my
pleasure to introduce you
to dr jackie mandel
lead technical product specialist
saitiba
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your
screen now if any questions arise during
the presentation
we encourage you to submit them in the q
a box our speaker will address your
questions
following the end of the presentation
please join me in welcoming dr jackie
mandel i will now turn the presentation
over to him
thank you for nice introduction
title of my presentation is the varied
application of dried blood spot
during copied 19 pandemic our mission is
to advance and accelerate therapeutics
my presentation will cover how sample
collection device
advance and accelerate faster diagnosis
the first step
of therapeutics
here is my agenda for this talk i'll
talk about what is sample collection
card
with the task of historical aspect of
sample
sample collection and diagnosis
applications of 903 card where i will
discuss how this sample collection card
reduce risk monitor surveillance in
cost-effective manner
i'll bring few examples and standard
protocols
of scitiva extractor nucleic acid micro
extraction
from sample collection card finally i
will discuss how your considerations
i'll discuss your considerations where
to apply this
technology let's start with
sample collection card
there are many names of sample
collection cards
whatman 903 card hotman sample
collection card dry blood spot card or
dbs card are alternatively used
that speak to the same purpose
occasionally it is referred to as
guthrie card the 903 cards rose to
prominence in 1962
after dr robert guthrie first published
procedures for screening
of newborn babies for phenylketonuria
phenylketonuria a disease
still affects one in 12 000 people
where penelope dehydrogenase that
converts
phenylalanine to tyrosine is defective
as a result
phenylalanine accumulates on the surface
of blood brain barrier
and impair other nutrient transport to
the brain
impairing brain's ability to protect
synthesis
since then good record samples from
two to nine day old babies have been
collected rootingly not only for
phenylketonuria but also for congenital
hypothyroidism and sickle cell disorders
the detection of markers of other
diseases such as human chorionic
gonadotropin
in down syndrome glycated hemoglobin
in insulin dependent diabetes and the
estimation of drug levels
abuse of drugs have also been
investigated
the limitations of sensitivity
and specificity when screening such
small
volume of blood such as 5 to 10
microliter restricted the use of
dried blood spot for many years however
recent advances such as the production
of monoclonal antibodies
expression of synthetic proteins and the
introduction of the polymerase chain
reaction or pcr have overcome many of
these problems
allowing the potential of a bus
bank of store dbs to be useful
by biochemist geneticist and
microbiologist
now the dbs system is the standard for
testing antibodies or proteins
vital rna or dna bacterial rna or dna
or human animal rna or dna the world
health organ
organization recommended procedure for
viral load results
obtained from plasma and dbs have
proven to be comparable recently
fda approved the vibrant antibody
chemiluminescence essay for
differentiating cells coronavitas to
igm and ig uh g
antibodies one what man 903 card
what was the guthrie card at that time
good record was basically
s and s or slicker and swirl 903
paper and hence it took the name 903
card
dbs card are made from 100 percent
cotton linter
with no additives what man carefully
ensures homogeneous composition
uniform thickness and absorbency
which ensure consistent sample recovery
and test performance
of hortman 903 cards 903 card is
a stable and cost effective method to
obtain blood samples on five spot
protein saver cards as shown
on the left two pictures sport
perforated protein silver cars
in the top middle protein silver snap
paper card in the right
moreover we offer any custom size cards
for
diverse volume of blood dry blood spot
card can be provided with
scannable barcodes maybe numbering
system
or with color code
the blood spot should then be allowed to
air dry and ideally stored in
low gas permeable bags that contain
desiccant to reduce humidity
samples can be tested immediately stored
at ambient temperature even under
tropical conditions are frozen
at -20 degree celsius where the level of
igg antibodies may remain stable
for several years some accessories
necessary for
the dried blood spot is drying
for drying and packaging drying the egg
is convenient tools hotmail drying rack
for
903 protein supercard is easily
assembled
can be affixed to a wall or countertop
with
optional who can hook and loop uh
stickers
file pack and desiccants for easy
shipping
for remote analysis
so now diverse application of
dbs
so intended uses for dbs samples
dbs obtained from children
and adults have been used for the
diagnosis of
infections and for sentinel
surveys in many parts of the world
surveillance surveillance detect acute
or
past exposure or infection for
surveillance both molecular and antibody
testing
can be used surveillance was world
health organizations mandate for hiv
infection service
now in this pandemic world health
organization is trying to understand
from kovite 19 pandemic surveillance
how much of the population has been
infected
with this cells coronavirus 2 causing
kobit 19. how is this changing over time
are there different characteristics or
risk factors
that are associated with certain
coronavirus to infection
such as is location or underlying health
conditions
how many residents experience mild or
symptomatic covid19 illness
how long can antibody be found after
coppet19 infection
also case management of suspects detect
active infection for case management of
suspects molecular
or antigen testing can be used
contracted tracing detect asymptomatic
or symptomatic
acute infection for contract tracing
molecular and antigen testing can be
used
monitoring response or recovery
for monitoring response or recovery both
molecular and antibody testing can be
used
prognosis uh for prognosis may be
cytokine response sometimes gives the
clear answer
but for environmental monitoring only
molecular detection is needed
there is world health organization
mandate about sample types
that allows plasma serum whole blood
fresh
or frozen or dbs sample in any sample
types the sensitivity and specificity
must meet regulatory guidelines
so other applications of dbs can be
has been proven to be useful for
hepatitis c hepatitis b
drug resistance viral load monitoring
human immunodeficiency sexual
transmitted disease bovine anti-brussel
abortions detection
malaria tuberculosis
for example about surveillance of
hiv actually in the
beginning of this surveillance it
initiated a huge doubt
over the sensitivity and specificity of
dbs-based tests
compared to plasma serum dbs contains
host cells
protein and nucleic acid whereas plasma
or serum has a kind of pure nucleic acid
from infectious organisms
so the dbs was not out of doubt about
its sensitivity and
specificity the other point was the
volume of sample
from dbs it's limited to five to ten
microliters so the
chance of false negative result was
another doubt
but dbs is compared to its serological
essay by parallel testing
of dbs and sarah which
showed 99 to 100 percent concordance
furthermore laboratory said the centers
for disease control atlanta extended the
screening quality assurance program
to include test panels of anti-hiv
positive
and negative dbs which were distributed
throughout the usa and overseas
subsequently
a similar quality control program was
made available
by the central public health laboratory
in london
since the inception of anonymous
screening
several millions dbs have been tested
enabling
accurate data to be obtained about the
prevalence of hiv one
similar surveillance has been done for
human
t cell leukemia or lymphoma virus it's
called stlb
sdlb one has been recognized as the
causal agent of adult t cell leukemia
transmission may occur by several means
including breast feeding and through
contaminated blood
in order to assess the extent of hdlb
or human t-cell leukemia lymphoma virus
in women of childbearing is a modified
gelatin particle assay
costing very little per test was used to
screen
over thousands dbas obtained from units
another example of surveillance was done
for
toxoplasma gandhi toxoplasma gandhi is
recognized to be a major cause of
congenital infection which may result in
mental retardation however the
prevalence of infection varies
widely in european countries a modified
latex text test consisting very little
per test has been used
for extensive service to determine the
maternal prevalence of antibodies
i should talk about detection of nucleic
acid in dbs
the potential for the use of dbs for the
detection of nucleic acid was first
realized in 1987
when dna was released from the filter
paper
by microextraction the molecular
analysis of dna obtained from neonates
has enabled detection of genetic
mutations
responsible for cystic fibrosis
oncogenesis
markers of type 1 diabetes and
thalassemia
the stability of dna has made it
possible to apply pcr to detect
provider hiv dna sequences several
months after sample collection even
when dbs had been held at room
temperature
recent studies have shown that hiv dna
and rna can be
recovered after five years without
refrigeration
an unexpected benefit
of storage is that inhibitors of pcr
such as protein hemoglobin
and iron seem to become increasingly
resistant to illusion
into the sample whereas nucleic acid
seems to aid stability
and does not impair its solution
so vital load monitoring for hiv this is
an practical example where it is being
used
so ministry of health global health
organization a part of cdc
[Music]
and national institute of health bright
blood spot
samples have been used for the detection
of
severe acute respiratory syndrome
carnovirus to spike antibodies
dbs sampling offers an alternative for
population-wide
serologic testing in the corner virus
pandemic
for vital load monitoring key products
used
are 903 cards or dbs cards accessories
such
as drying racks
so another example of use of
903 card in national scientific
institute medical research
in in oils where scientists have
developed a convenient
low-cost antibody test for covid19 based
on dried blood spot
sampling technique the novel antibody
test uses a single drop of blood
and blot it on a specialized 903 cards
the cards can then be shipped to
laboratories for testing once there is
the laboratory a disk is punched out
from the card and the antibodies are
released
using a specialized liquid called
extraction buffer
they have optimized the enzyme leak
enzyme-linked immunosorbent assay or
elisa
antibody test to be used with the dbs
method
and translating the test onto an
automated platform
will allow hundreds of samples to be
tested at once
now i'll give you some examples of
collection protocol
sample collection by a skin puncture
blood can be collected from skin
puncture or
venipuncture venous blood is the
specimen of choice for
more rooting left test or reference
ranges
but skin punctured blood is preferred
for remote sample collection
or when sample amount of blood
when small amount of blood is adequate
for the test
and the specimen of choice for
pediatrics
elderly severely burned patients with
thrombotic
tendencies extremely obese apprehensive
patients and home-based test
small amount of blood is easier to
manage
in remote areas such as home or clinics
the collection on dbs is pretty simple
right after finger prick apply pressure
allow a large
drop of free flowing blood to collect
quickly and gently toss card with blood
let blood soak through repeat until at
least
all circles are filled
be sure fill out the name
and date or other special requirements
on the cards
once the card is dried they are
ready to ship and now what are the
advantages of dbs
number one advantages is reduction of
risk
the collection of capillary blood or
filter paper
is simple to perform requires minimal
training and
doesn't involve the risk associated with
use and disposal of needles and syringes
the dbs represents a low infectious
hazard
as some viruses such as hiv 1 and 2
human t-cell leukemia
1 and 2 and hepatitis c virus
that are known to be present in serum or
plasma
but they lose infectivity during
due to disruption of their envelope
on drying process however virus in high
titer
may remain viable on a surface for
several days and hepatitis b
virus may remain infectious for at least
seven days
risks associated with shipping are
minimized as dbs cannot leak
or be broken in transit and there is no
requirement for caries on dry ice
handling of potentially infected
material
is also reduced as there is no need to
centrifuge
and separate syrup from blood clots
there is another economic advantage
collection and processing of dbs is
considerably cheaper
at least three to five times cheaper
than samples collected by venu puncture
tbs can be readily shipped in silt
envelopes to reference centers where
whereas sera need to be packed in
brake proof containers transport of
frozen setup may require
the use of dry ice or liquid nitrogen
requiring further specialized handling
and adding considerable weight to the
item
the majority of the diagnostic technique
for example
particular agglutination test and enzyme
immunizes
which have been used to screen for
antibodies in dbs
are simple and generally require little
capital expenditure
the use of the agglutination test is
particularly cost effective as they can
be performed in the absence
of an electricity supply this is ideally
suited to countries
with limited health deposits
and surveillance for large-scale
epidermal is
epidemic epidemiological uh service
can be performed rapidly enabling
strategic
decisions to be made about targeting
at-risk population
this may be particularly valuable for
monitoring
heart immunity and the extent of vaccine
coverage
at a time of eradication
sativa genomics and molecular solutions
optimize dbs card sample collection and
dilution for molecular diagnostic of
sars coronavirus 2
the process is pretty simple using only
application of 20 microliter of blood on
903 cards
dry for about 3 hours in room 10 remove
12 millimeter punch from 903 card
homogenize and extract sample using the
sera extractor virus pathogen kit
so what is extract a virus pathogen kit
this kit has been developed in response
to global kobit 19 pandemic
and aimed to address current challenges
faced with supplying kids for testing
and scientific research the format of
the kid
and a rapid protocol provide an
excellent high throughput solution
that should aid in global efforts of
scientific
and medical community to detect and
study the virus
so extract a virus kit offers the
advantages of solid phase
extraction using magnetic beads nucleic
acid samples are allowed to bind on
magnetic bead surface
this is called solid face surface
washing out the
unbound samples and eluting pure nucleic
acids
ready to run the test the protocol can
be adapted for
both manual and automated high
throughput processing
deputy extraction procedure can be done
in less than 30 minutes using diverse
sample matrices such as blood and
universal transport
transport media at low concentration
still extractor virus kit is compatible
with molecular biology techniques
including
quantitative polymerase chain reaction
droplet digital pcr
and next generation sequencing in
addition
a recent study found that on cardboard
no bible search corner virus 2 was
measured
after 24 hours
so this is the result uh for the
detection of sars coronavirus 2
by syria extract a virus pathogen kit
from 903 card
in this graph sars coronavirus 2 is
diluted in coupon universal
transport medium with human cells
rna extraction done from 903 card
within 24 hours which we can call t0
in the lift 3 extraction
of the graph t
rna extraction from 903 card within
14 days we can call it t14
shown last two extraction of the of the
graph
so t0 and t14 so the first three graph
and the first three bars and
last two bars were compared with liquid
samples in the middle
to extraction pcr amplification was done
using
non-nuclear protein primer sets and rns
negative control
as per cdc guidelines only samples for
which the anon
marker crossed the threshold at city
values are considered positive
so no implic amplification in the anon
kovite 19 specific primer set
were observed in unspiked controls and
spiked negative controls when not shown
in this graph
in this slide whole human blood stored
at room temperature on what men 903
cards for
24 hours which is called t0
and 14 days as a t14
ct values obtained for the n on kovid 19
specific primer set
with 50 copies per microliter or
thousand
copies per extraction of the heat
inactivated viral rna
in the input sample and human specific
rnsp
primer set are presented
error bars represent standard deviation
note that kobit 19 specific
amplification was not detected in
any of the unspiked control samples
uh city undetermined data not showed
so this extractor bias kit provides
efficient total nucleic acid
recovery from different samples type and
in different concentrations with high
sensitivity in downstream
detection
so here are some uh important
considerations
before using whatman 903 card
all hortman 903 card protein silver
cards
are marked for research use only
meaning you need regulatory such as fda
ua or country specific approval
to incorporate a dbs card into your test
let me answer some common questions how
does
no3 903 card work
actually is for biomolecules
are that are bound to the cellulose
fiber matrix
capturing the sample for a one watt
analysis upon extraction
what sample type can i apply to 903 card
paper
typically blood but any blue bodily
fluid can be applied
how should i store the unused 903 card
recommendation for the storage of 903
cars is
at least at less than 25 degree celsius
and 60 degree
relative humidity protected from direct
sunlight
what is the shelf life of an unused 903
card is 5 years
very long shelf life if it is in
sativa package what
panzer can be used with 903 card
any puncher most mostly
used any sponsor can be used
what accessories such as sponsor and mat
mats does saitiba provide we do not have
any punchers
punches we offer but do have houses
and desiccant we can offer
to make up a kit what happens if nitric
oxides get
wet either before or after storage if
the 903 card gets wet prior to sample
collection discard the unused weight
card
if the product gets wet after sample
application
take a punch from the specimen so
as soon as possible and continue
processing
how do we apply the blood or other
liquid on samples
onto 903 cards products are provided
with an protocol showing how sample
should be applied can i
reapply sample to the card after this
part has dried
to get more sample onto the 903 card not
necessary
because the amount of sample
you will have for past application you
will be good enough
can custom formats be made yes our
design
team can work with you to produce a
device that will
fit your needs
right can you apply previously frozen
blood to 903 cards to purify sample
yes a larger puns may be needed
though as some of these cells may have
been
lysed on freezing how many punches can i
get from 1903
sample circles depends on the punch
diameter
and circle size
you can determine can i elude dna from
903 card
in principle yes with the help of
protein sk
treatment and a phenol chloroform
isomyelic alcohol
at 2524 1 ratio
extraction uh yes this application is
quite possible
what do you mean by excessive humidity
during storage what about humidity
during shipment
of spotted and or unspotted product
humidity may compromise the sample
by molecules degradation could occur
there we recommend to use a sealed bag
containing a desiccant packet how much
blood does
is card hold that's a good one
this depends on number of circles per
card each circle sample area holds
75 to 80 microliter of sample maximum
400 microliter for cards with five
sample areas
what certification is available
certificate of analysis is available for
nine or three paper
used for each job we normally do not
provide
a job-specific certificate of analysis
contrary of origins or origin
certificates
which is supplied for export countries
as a mandatory document are msts
available
no material data safety sheet are
available
[Music]
as no chemicals are not available as no
chemicals are used for this product
what types of barcode can you print
sativa can print most barcodes that
are utilized in the industry using
high speed laser printer city back and
customize to any barcode size
and is also able to paint 2d barcodes
can you print barcodes 1903 filter paper
because of the nature of 903 filter
paper
and its high absorbency sciteva does not
recommend
trying to print barcodes directly onto
the 903 paper
what is your typical delivery
the complexity of the card and
volume can affect delivery however the
majority of orders can be processed
and shipped six to eight weeks after
pure
receipt and customer copy approval
uh this that was my last slide let's
keep in touch
thank you very much for your time i can
take your questions
dr mandel can you hear me okay yes very
good
okay sounds good okay well dr model i
want to thank you for that outstanding
presentation
we will now move into the live q a
portion of our webinar
now as a reminder to our audience please
submit your questions
via the q a box okay
we have lots of questions so let's just
jump right in
our first question
how can i get more detail on the
protocols of
how to use 903 cards in the many
applications you've mentioned in this
presentation
all right let me get the question
uh from the bottom
all right just a second
sure all right um i
get uh protocols on how to use 903 cards
in many applications you have messed in
this
uh presentation yeah many applications
for example
a nucleic acid test or antibody test
or some specific biomarkers
depending on the type of samples you're
collecting
say if it is uh blood samples
so there are three ways you can collect
the blood uh
finger pricking or belly puncture or
arterial puncture
and you also can collect any kind of
biofluid
like in vince liba so depending on your
sample type
you your collection protocol will be
different
but the process is very simple we have
the
protocol that how much sample can be
applied per sec
depending on that volume you can use
the certain volume to apply on the
903 card after drying for three hours at
room temperature
and you can collect the punch
using a punch puncher
and elute your samples and simple
illusion or sample preparation is
variable depending on the type of test
and compatibility of your reagent
but the straightforward processes just
punch it out
once they cut out and elude your samples
into
into a right buffer which is suitable
for your test
excellent thank you our next question
can you speak to other sample collection
methods that you've used
all right i already discussed the
fingerprint
fingerprinting sample collection
involves
taking a very small amount of blood from
the patient
usually from the end of the finger
but arterial sampling
which is close to the palm
and this blood sample
commonly takes place within a hospital
environment
arterial sampling it is used in the
identification of metabolic respiratory
and mixed acid-based disorders where
carbon dioxide levels require
understanding or monitoring there is an
increased risk of bleeding complications
in patients
with quad glucopathy but
benue puncture is most common way to
collect blood from adult patients from a
superficial vein in the upper limb
this uh vein is close to the skin
and doesn't have many large nerves
positioned close by
uh this reduces pain and discomfort
for the patient there are also risks
related to the storage transportation
and potential loss of
contamination of the blood samples once
they are collected
so other than blood saliva urine or any
biofluid can be collected on sample
collection card
thank you let's go with this one
are there use case examples in this
pandemic that you can speak of
oh definitely recently fda
fda approved the vibrant
antibody chemi luminescence essay
for differentiating cers
coronovitis to igm and igg antibodies
one whatman 903 card world health
organization is trying to understand
from kobit 19 pandemic surveillance
world health organization has approved
dbs system for acib surveillance and now
stepping up with dbs sample to
understand sars karna virus 2
as well and also well scientists have
developed a convenient look with
antibody chest for public 19
based on dried blood spot sampling
technique
it's also an automated elisa format
so these are the common examples but we
have been working with many customers
who are trying to dbs card to
incorporate
into their lateral flow system as a
sample collection device
and lateral flow test for the detection
of that sample
and finally probably this lateral flow
with the dbs card will be
approved by fda or other
eu system yes excellent
thank you now how long can samples be
stored
and what are the best storage conditions
um once
once after sample collection uh
depending
on the analyte target it could be
antibody nucleic acid
the length of sample stability may vary
for example nucleic acid dna and rna rna
is
unstable on any sample on
any condition
in any condition either liquid or in dry
blood spot so samples can be tested
immediately
or usually can be stored in ambient
temperature even under
tropical conditions or frozen at minus
20 minus 80 degrees celsius
where the level of igc antibodies may
remain stable for several years
but the stability of dna and rna
may be variable but it has been tested
by pcr and dna sequences several months
after sample collection
even when dbs had been held at room
temperature
a recent study have shown that hiv dna
and
rna can be recovered after five years
without refrigeration as well
excellent dr mondel as swabs are in
short supply
could 903 cards be used to collect
saliva
mucus swabs for covid19
antigen detection
so it has not been tested but
saliva antigen
for kobit 19 definitely it can be
collected
on a 903 card and
the customer has to evaluate this is
kind of new antigen we don't know many
characteristics customer has to be
evaluate the stability
of the 903 card with sars coronavirus to
antigen
thank you and with time for a few more
questions
let's go with this one are there any
higher contamination risks
as compared to other sampling methods
definitely finger pricking is much safer
than any other uh methods of sample
collection
as you as we know flavortomy
the drawing of blood has been practiced
for centuries and still one of the most
common
invasive procedures in healthcare is
taping the process of
libertarian such as collecting blood
shipping opening the tube
and take the samples for testing
affects the quality of the specimen and
involvement of
human hands work which is
who is caused the error in many ways
and it also caused the injury for the
patient
for example the touch of a finger
to verify the location of vein
before insertion of the needle increases
the chance that
a specimen will be contaminated from the
hands and these can cause
false results prolong hospitalization
delay
diagnosis and cause and unnecessary use
of antibiotics
also jostling and
gearing of the test tubes in the transit
can lies or break open red blood cells
causing false laboratory tests as well
so similar finger pricking
and 903 card sample collection even
though it is safer
but definitely it requires
human involvement to clean the
fingertips
and drop the blood uh so
uh the precaution should be taken for
finger pricking as well
um but this is definitely much safer
than
venue puncture blood collection
now piggybacking off on that question
and answer
can you elaborate what the common root
causes
are when sampling is done incorrectly
using these cards right the
root causes could lie in
every steps every steps that
human or the sample collecting person
is taking people not
storing the product correctly even after
sample collection and is not
transporting in timely
way to the lab say finger pricking at
the time of
finger pricking finger must be clean
apply pressure during
say blood is not dropping out and you
need to apply a tiny pressure during
pressure if your hand
like move away from the circle
then you might spot somewhere else
and and allow a large drop for
free flowing blood to collect
sometimes when the circle is full you
have to remove your hand
away so or also
so during the touching uh when the blood
is dropping from the finger
the card uh should be in contact with
blood
and is it is a kind of
um tricky and you have to maintain this
properly and um
and also the drying condition if the
blood is not completely dry
so and if you put in a package so the
blood might contaminate some other
area of the card even the envelope
um which could be risky for the handler
so the drying condition is one of the
critical
and then um you have to fill out
the name and date of other special end
date and some other special requirement
once the card is dried it is ready to
ship and
then you have to ship it properly so
there are many steps involved
so every step could be faulty if it is
not
accurately maintained
thank you that's some great information
we have time for one more question
let's go with this one i need to track
and automate
my sampling process what options do you
have
right dry blood spot card can be
provided
with scannable barcodes which
we which we are able to customize upon
request
we are also working in development to
help
create a framed version of the 903 card
which is compatible with
automation equipment such as the
hamilton eg puns
starlet more more information is coming
please follow once available
great thank you so much
we are out of time but i want to tell
our audience don't worry because those
questions that were submitted and we
were unable to get to
they will be answered via email and we
have your registered animation in your
email
at dr mondel thank you again so much and
thank you again to our audience for
their outstanding questions oh thank you
so much
for your cooperation and you have been
working so hard
uh from the beginning of this conference
and and
uh for this presentation and thank you
my audience for listening
if you have any question please feel
free to contact me directly
we'll be happy to answer your questions
thank you dr mandel now i want to tell
our audience as well that today's
presentation
is available for on-demand viewing for
12 months
so please remember to share this with
your colleagues who may be interested in
this topic
you may also submit questions during
that on-demand period
now don't miss out on the other
presentations on our agenda those that
have already presented live
are now available on demand so visit
that agenda tab in the auditorium for a
full listing
thank you again for your participation
and dr mandel thank you again for your
time today
thank you very much have a great day